nouvelle saison je voulais poser la
vaccination contre la covit à tous les
fonctionnaires et envoyer des sociétés
des temps va faire le point on vous
propose de regarde d'abord celui du
droit on fait le point avec maître
avocat des droits de la personne dans
100 mètres Grey
est-ce que vous vous attendez est-ce que
ça soit contester
oui je pense que ça peut être contestée
et il est évident qu'il y a une relation
de la Charte des droits et libertés
c'est pas fait au départ parce que les
violations peuvent être justifié la
charte d'être car quand il
y a beaucoup de cas où
que malgré la violation technique
il y a quoi
pour le premier c'est ce que le
gouvernement a un but louable pense que
ça ne peut pas de doute ici
pour
est-ce qu'il y a un
début à
tout
[Musique]
la majorité des gens
soutenable mais si je devais partir je
dirais que le gouvernement va gagner
plusieurs raisons d'abord parce que dans
les cas de crise et on est en crise par
exemple
généralement les
deux
fonctions dans la société
[Musique]
voir sur la 3e. Vous avez évoqué la
c'est-à-dire au moins contraignant on
comprend déjà que le gouvernement
aurait peut-être des exceptions pour les
gens qui ont des conscience qu'il faut
en sorte qu'ils ne peuvent pas être
vacciné
pour des raisons
de santé est-ce que c'est pour
rester avec vous par exemple
mais on reste quand même
c'est un argument sous-plat en direct
dont le travail peut être fait par
télétravail ils n'ont pas vraiment des
contacts avec un
argument
sur la
conscience et et
et
sinon
je pense que oui
[Musique]
je m'en a fait une chose qui est très
dépendant table il se peut qu'il va y
avoir une arguments et certaines et du
Coran présenter des arguments
intéressant mais
surtout je pense que le gouvernement pas
en sortir vainqueur merci pour votre
regard maître Grey
au plaisir au revoir
maintenant un autre regard celui du
monde de la santé avec Docteur et
Patrick Bellemare c'est le chef médical
des soins intensifs du nord de nord de
l'île de Montréal voilà il était aussi
bonsoir d'abord docteur Bellemare
vous en pensez quoi vous êtes libre ce
soir pour les fonctionnaires fait des
ressources d'accord avec ça
désaccord avec une mesure qui nous
permet
de vivre l'isolement qu'on a vécu comme
ça c'est la seule alternative
on en fait on a rencontré au cours de la
dernière année que
avec la fermeture de la société
exceptionnellement déjà vacciné je vous
dirai donc dans la grande majorité des
fois c'est les gens qui n'ont pas été
vacciné ou pas été vacciné complètement
personnellement des gens non vacciné
complètement j'en ai vu aucun ma
pratique
mais fédéral ils disent tous les outils
actuellement qui sont accessibles pour
pousser les gens vers la vaccination on
dit la quatrième vague ça soit des noms
est-ce que vous pensez que assez de non
vacciné ou de peau complètement avec
nous pour avoir un impact sérieux encore
une fois sur les soins prodigués dans
les hôpitaux qui provoque un rapport de
stage
Bah à regarder les courbes que vous
publiez vous-même
que je sois poster à la douane pour être
capable de vous dire avec certitude ce
que je vous souhaite la majorité des
corps qu'on voit paraître c'est les gens
qui sont complètement vacciné ou non
vacciné c'est pas un problème de voyage
à l'étranger